Joe Biden this is the elderly man
pretending to be president he has
dementia everyone knows it they're
throwing him up uh for 24 which is
absolutely completely ridiculous he gave
the commencement speech at Howard
University it is a historically black
college and uh stoked the racial Flames
enjoy
stand up against the poison
the white supremacists I did my
inaugural address to a single out
as the most dangerous terrorist threat
to our homeland is white supremacy
[Applause]
and I'm not saying this because I'm at a
black hpcu
I say Wherever I Go
oh shut up you old windbag that's
exactly why you're saying it because
you're a pandering old buffoon and
what's funny is that line was obviously
not written on the speech right like
that's the part I'm not saying this
because I'm in a room with a whole bunch
of black people but screw Whitey yeah
okay yeah we love it we love it oh
the oldest most Sinister forces
May believe they'll determine America's
future but they are wrong we will
determine America's future it's just
terrible
[Music]
foreign